osti giovani d'oggi sempre attaccati al
suo telefonino mio nipote usa quello lì
delle foto d'epoca più easy star all
oggetto anche tu io ma figurati non ho
me non piace mettere le mie cose su
quelle quesiti lì io guarda l'unica cosa
che faccio quando manca qualcuno è che
vedo che c'è l'annuncio su facebook
scrivo con dorian se metto 23 likes e
basta ma invece sai cosa hanno capito io
quel quel sito la dei giovani il tic toc
assise quello cinese o e cinese bastano
a quante cose che si inventano si fanno
quei pali con le robe strane ii che lo
chiamano ballare ma sembra aderisce
muniti a perché in televisione invece
tutti gli a mostrarsi a farsi vedere io
guardo solo gli sceneggiati più mi è
piaciuto tanto uno li di docs con
argentario ha sì quello dei dottori a
che bello ben piaciuto anche a me quello
è comunque varotti stipite col
telefonino attaccato la faccia mi fanno
proprio paura l'altro giorno ho visto un
bambino avrà avuto neanche tre anni così
col telefonino ma o robe da matti